welcome to ghostwire tokyo
a supernatural action-adventure thriller
set in an eerie haunting vision of tokyo
with explosive first-person combat
and dangerous monsters at its core
after nearly all of tokyo's population
mysteriously vanishes
the city is flooded with supernatural
creatures
our story begins here in the fallout of
the vanishing you awake in the deserted
streets of tokyo with an unknown voice
inside your head and strange elemental
powers coursing through your veins
possessed by a mysterious spirit named
kk who has his own agenda you'll need to
work together to unravel the truth
behind the disappearances
and save the city from this twisted
nightmare
in ghostwire tokyo you'll harness an
arsenal of powerful abilities through a
mystic art known as ethereal weaving
channeling raw ether
such as wind
fire
and water
as the story unfolds you'll learn to
upgrade and master these abilities based
on your play style
incorporating powerful choreographs
and perfectly timed blocks all to
devastating effect
alongside your abilities you'll have a
range of more traditional and mystical
tools at your disposal
traversal and exploration are a central
part of ghostwire tokyo
and with the tengu ability players can
grapple and maneuver through the city
with ease
areas of dense fog not only harbor dark
energy that drains your health but are
infested with deadly paranormal
creatures
to clear these infected areas you'll
need to cleanse corrupted tory gates
scattered throughout the city
and by freeing untethered souls you'll
acquire experience to upgrade your
ethereal abilities
throughout tokyo you'll discover strange
distortions in reality known as utena
spaces where time
and space themselves cannot be trusted
and the only way to complete your
mission
is to power through them
in this video we want to bring together
these mechanics to show you the world's
first extended gameplay preview of ghost
wire tokyo
we pick up at a moment where aikido and
kk have been separated
leaving aikido with only his wits and
traditional weapons
aikido must track the spirit down
sneak attacks and core grabs are a great
way to clear your path without
attracting unwanted attention
foreign
foreign
go guys
good
now that you're reunited with kk you can
use his powers again
and gain access to devastating
supercharged attacks
from now on as you fight you'll charge
your synergy with kk at full charge you
can enter wire in mode to boost your
powers
to grapple between buildings you'll need
to latch on to the nearest tengu yokai
these creatures are not only the fastest
way to get around but they also open a
new dimension to the city
the corrupted tory gate is just ahead
cleanse it to clear out some of the
sinister fog throughout the city
[Music]
as you progress your powers will grow
and with many enemy archetypes to fight
you'll need to evolve your abilities and
strategies to take on these supernatural
threats
[Music]
explore the city and you'll also find
other tools and weapons like these
talismans to expand your combat options
[Music]
ah
[Music]
using spectral vision you're able to
sense visitors in other points of
interest as you make your way through
tokyo
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
you